I feel like it's not appropriate to
start without acknowledging a birthday
that we have here okay this is our first
live-action Star Wars television show
can you guys talk a little bit about
what is so appealing about that you guys
it's how I put it there's as somebody
who grew up with Star Wars and and
really having been formed around what I
experienced when I was little with the
first film there was some aesthetic to
it that I think that I really loved that
I really gravitated to and my whole
taste in movies was probably formed in a
big way from seeing George Lucas's
original film and and I learned about
cinema through through the lens of that
film because my father would explain to
me no that's you know this isn't this is
a lot like samurai movie this is a lot
like westerns or world war ii films and
so that became my inroad and then there
was the whole power of myth with Joseph
Campbell and the lawyers that was filmed
up at the ranch and that opened me up to
the mythic structure and the monomyth
and my understanding of mythology and
storytelling and so to come back and
return to this with the freedom that
this new platform affords because
there's nothing to compare it to nothing
has been on TV other than the holiday
special and the the idea of telling us
over more than just a couple of hours
told every few years opens us up to this
novelization of story and a return back
to the roots in many ways of the
Saturday afternoon serial films and my
parents generation grew up with with
cliffhangers adventure and those drawing
from that type of stylish storytelling
lets itself really well to what we're
what we're tackling here and so there's
also a you know it's fun not to have a
preciousness in the way we're telling
stories because you know we have we're
coming back to you next week with
another one and so to engage the
audience in a way that I had joy being
engaged with the shows with the film
specific specifically what BBC had done
with streaming services where it's
bigger budget it has a lot of the
qualities and aesthetics of the film but
the novelization of the serialized
storytelling to me that's where it
really opened up a lot of freedom an
opportunity where we don't feel that
we're repeating or copying anything else
that people have experienced from Star
Wars I just thought the whole thing you
say I think as a kid growing up you
watch Star Wars you think I would watch
this every week and as television got
more and more into genre over the years
and like I remember when Star Trek next
generation came out and the promise of
better better visual effects on
television and it took big leaps and you
know somebody that's always been into
fantasy science fiction you were always
waiting for a moment where you thought
that what the images on television were
as good as what we were seeing in the
theater but there was a big separation
line as a kid and now I think it's
gotten so close and you know it's one of
the drug
we can make something like Star Wars
because technology has advanced and it's
that's one of the dreams of the drawer
chat even when I worked with him long
words he would talk about the future
being streaming the future being
episodic serialized Star Wars like you
said it's what influenced him so yeah
and it is cool to get to help make it so
I like that
when I tell you I crying for that
footage I'm being serious oh really yes
the first time people are seeing
anything 7 minutes yes and we compile we
want to compile little bits from
different episodes because I think also
part of what's fun about this is that
and with this new service is that
everybody wherever they are if they have
the service there they're seeing it
first you know and and it's nice to be
able to show stuff to people to
understand what it is so you can talk
about it and and you know kind of cut
through all of the how crowded the
marketplace is with so many stories and
so many services so it's nice to have
everybody here to react to it which is
which is really helpful in getting the
word out but it's also nice to have
people to be able to be everybody to
experience something at the same time
which is what I really loved about
watching my game of Thrones is that
there's a sense of what's going to
happen in this this week and and the
idea that it's not cascading down now of
course the service isn't available
everywhere yet hopefully that's gonna
that's gonna be you know over as it as
it rolls out hopefully everybody around
the world will be able to have that same
experience but for us it's a really fun
dialogue that we're looking forward to
that we usually normally get
the conventions where you get to show it
people get to react and then you get to
talk about it and it gets us excited as
filmmakers and then that dialog unfolds
over the course of and I'm happy it's
being released you know at a rhythm
because it gives us a chance although
we're not able to react in what we're
doing because all those episodes are
done and it certainly will inform what
we're doing the second season we were
actually in first week first week of the
second seasons under our belt and our
cast when you see them especially Pedro
a little tired
they're quite late last night should we
bring out this this entire class please
welcome Pedro Pascal Gina Carano and
Carl Weathers
[Applause]
did you think you may get some sleep or
just power through welcome to the party
okay now looking at this footage
companies keep mentioning how
unbelievable it was I can't imagine what
it was like for you guys on set what was
the moment you realized I'm truly in the
Star Wars universe hey there what was it
for you well putting the helmet on for
sure which they had handed our first
meeting and to see if it would fit and
fit perfectly and and and and I guess
you know very simply trying to cost
lunch or something and looking in the
paper heard you can't see very well to
the helmet but but I I got I got a
pretty clear impression and if you grow
up you know playing the Star Wars toys
and obviously see these reason then
you're staring at yourself in and you
are the image of that kind of childhood
imagination it's a super pinch me moment
quote me exactly super super [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
and John de Jun de sort of a slow roll
on me
it's like beatnik it's like okay I've
got this thing that I wouldn't want to
talk to you about and okay and first of
all I've met John so we had a lot of
interaction even though it wasn't like
good personal personal stuff but we got
a lot of interaction and I really admire
him and I'm sincere about that I really
admired him because this guy is super
smart ridiculously smart about much more
than just making movies so that was
number one so I'm fascinated I'm saying
okay that those are the kind of people I
want to be around and know so I can
maybe play crap grab something that he's
got that I really admire oh by the way I
don't know if you folks would notice I'm
going to
- happy birthday whistle 2300 so we
could given the chance do something with
you you know the thing is when when when
we finally had a meeting about it and
not on my favorite of the disturbing
bucket in that room that conference
treatment all this part is on the walls
and he is so passionate about it all and
it's all magnificent I mean it is some
of the most beautiful art work you could
receive you were a collector you want to
go through and take pieces off the wall
cuz it's that beautiful and then start
telling me basically what this was we've
got this character and it's like a
community and I'm working on something
that Disney is going to be behind I'm
working on something that Jon Favreau is
like Marcia went through and I'm working
on a Star Wars kind of invention and
then I get a chance to meet Dave Bologna
now it's like we really did rope him in
this is he's not kidding
it started off with a maybe you'll do
you know now we really liked it care I
know this you know we're talking about
this but I'm not writing the last you
know so I don't want to say too much but
but we worked him in a lot into the show
more than he agreed to and now in season
two he's a part of our directors of
brigades
the directors guild so he actually meant
has of course I was a fan of his acting
but but he's been more directing lately
so that's been fun so this whole of this
whole high tech innovative set that
we've developed for these specific
stories by crawl being there and being
part of it and seeing how we were
putting this together and experimenting
with it and seeing it all come together
he was perfectly qualified that he
understood the story understood the
characters the cast and the technology
and so it's really fun to be working
with Karl now on my story but but you
know I gotta hit the ball back because
honestly I don't think it would have
happened with a lot of people John
promised last year when I agreed to do
this because he knows I wanted to direct
more and more that even got a second
season that he gave me a shot and I get
to tell you I've been around enough to
know that people don't always keep their
words you know and it was like
absolutely director do you think well
speaking of the directors there are a
lot of things that you guys have pulled
in I don't
is anybody else Howard tackle on TV Dave
Filoni I mean he talked a little bit
about what their contributions are and
it's Davis versus I'm drawing live
action over here did a couple for us and
so forget her child she's a child who's
going on now to do the obi-wan Kenobi
show the cetera so she came into store
so this is really you're going to see I
think a lot of people that are working
in this incubator of story and
technology and and start in a really
people who got together because they
love Star Wars and this I think
enthusiasm that seems to be very
contagious not just with the people on
the couch here but the art where he's
talking about you know that's up Chang
who's been part of a lot of people who
came up through the ranks over the years
since the prequels and and all of them
slowly like Tom Sawyer coming together
dependent paying the fence and there's
this real enthusiasm that's very organic
as we're time stories and it's a very
collaborative environment you know we
talk a lot of that story and I write
most of it but that's just a jumping-off
point for the directors to be very
involved very collaborative and all the
people who are involved whether it's a
lamb or Lucasfilm were within the
Kastner Mandalorian and so it becomes
this really fun collaborative thing that
takes on its own life and on personality
and I think you'll see with each of the
directors unlike a lot of television the
directors are really being given an
opportunity to have authorship over it
is over
so it's been very exciting for us to
have that kind of environment to come to
work to everyday
John you posted a photo of George Lucas
and yourself on set can you talk about
that experience he was on set that day
what you talked about that you drink the
wine we had been and drink the wine that
day I don't think I'll ever drink that
wine right on the mantel from Skywalker
but crawl was there that day and I think
Gina was the other than know for sure I
know for sure this guy was there because
I met Dave because I was up at the ranch
and mixing iron man and he was secretly
working with George on Clone Wars before
anybody had ever heard of it and I
showed him Iron Man he showed me Clone
Wars I was like if you ever need a voice
on this I'd love to do it was turned
into me playing a Mandalorian entry
vizla on his on his show but what's so
nice is that George had worked with him
for what 10 10 years and so they had
worked together so a lot of what's
wonderful about working with dave is
that that continuity of vision and I
know George really I think came by more
to see you know if it came with Cathy
because they have a you know a
long-standing relationship but the thing
that really stood out and he didn't say
in front of Dave but isn't one embarrass
him but he's was very I could see that
he was very proud of that heap dave was
getting down in that step because when
George discovered dave dave was just an
animator that he brought in I'm sure
you've heard the story or he'll tell it
where he didn't even he thought it was a
joke that his criteria we're pulling a
prank on him and then after never George
I said do you want to run the show and
so it's been a long relationship
and understanding filmmaking
understanding Star Wars and now as we
get into live-action to take the next
step so I think that's a big reason he
was there was because he was one make
sure I was uh I think continuing the
Dave's a journey with him very it was
great it felt very special you know very
very special well Dave you've been
excellent about pulling kind of beloved
characters into them and curse words in
Star Wars Canon is there anyone that
maybe we could be looking out for in the
Mandalorian that you could it be
terribly learn about anything in a you
know here now rather than watching it
that's really the most organic moment
and everybody will be excited I mean
this has been a real special thing for
me it's something that I realized in
live-action I became interested in it
from working with George and the way
that he talked about how we should shoot
Clone Wars and he would always speak in
live-action terms the terminology was
always around that and I didn't always
understand how to apply it over the
years though I got a little better with
it and he's so steeped in technology
George and pushing technology previous
systems stuff like that on plumbers that
it just became a part of the language of
filmic for me as well and working with
John is really natural it kind of
continues that because he's very
forward-thinking with technology and
using tools to help enable greater
storytelling and I saw that you know
general was just incredibly so very
inspirational II and with the work that
he's done in Lion King and whatnot so
for me it was a great opportunity to
work with somebody that kind of works in
it
some are vague that I can really be
challenged and John has challenged me I
will say that creatively storytelling
wise and you need that sharpening you
need to improve and and continue a
legacy of bed you know frankly being
mentored I see it as very Star Wars this
whole path for me I've had a couple men
towards now I'm very privileged to have
the ones that I've had and I think my
storytelling is definitely even better
for John you know taking me in and
showing me the ropes of doing live
action and just my own writing and it's
a you know I say this it's affecting
Clone Wars in the greatest way possible
for what I've done on that series I've
improved it I think in the storytelling
thanks to this experience work a
mentorian but is there any you know
surprises and they're always surprises I
would I wouldn't know what made you cry
any more that I would know what might
surprise people say rather that's really
got a surprise well I think at this
point we're gonna open it up to the
audience here and we've got a couple
mics going around I saw your hand first
but I think well we'll start here hi
Congrats guys they looked amazing thank
you for joining Dave you mentioned Taika
Waititi he's obviously also voicing a
character and the show can you talk
about what he brings to the show it's
like to work with him well you know when
you bring in a director like Tyga that
he's clearly doing it because he wants
to because the guy is just such a
powerhouse right now creatively and I
think
discovering what a talent he is people
who follow comedy knew about him long
ago or independent filament now he's
just he's really enjoying a wonderful
run and so what he shows up it gets
everybody excited because it's a fresh
energy on the set he finds opportunities
for humor he brings his style of humor
to it but he also is a fan and that was
that to to me that was the bottom line
prerequisite he didn't have to be the
most experienced and have to have worked
on Star Wars before you didn't even have
to have ever directed live-action before
we had a few people as we said that
hadn't done that the thing was that you
had to be willing to collaborate he had
to love Star Wars and you had to want to
do you want he had to want to do
something great and helped invent this
new thing and to have type it in there
somebody who was a we know
battle-hardened veteran who could come
in and just has tremendous instincts in
to work with the actors and to bring
that for me you know to just be able to
work with him I had known him for a
while and from the Marvel world we had
been sharing experiences that we've had
but to actually be on the set and to
witness what he did was was tremendous
and then and if they haven't played do
the voice of IG 11 and bring that
specific tome to that character but also
the tones who listened directly it was
fantastic I'm grateful to him for that
first of all congratulations on the show
the footage was awesome I'm curious the
making of the first season of any show
you're learning the infrastructure of
how to put it together what you can
accomplish in the timeframe etc except
for for each of you guys what did you
learn making season one that you are now
putting into season two and when will
you announce the other directories of
season 2 things I've been I was on set
every day the whole season so I have
learned watching every single one of our
directors I learned watching our great
cast everyone behind the scenes that I
treated is you know boot camp for me to
learn this type of filmmaking but then I
tried to offer the knowledge that I've
been passed on to be by George for Star
Wars things and the way that we like to
shoot things but it definitely has
affected the way I look at you know a
day what can I accomplish in a day
that's a big difference for me
filmmaking wise we arrived on the
backlot and the DP Craig's like well the
Sun's up a guy get going oh that's
alright cuz it's gonna go down
[Laughter]
so even though you're getting on Sixers
fly and everyone gets squirrelly and
you're like the sun's going down the
sun's going down like right then we're
screwed
so that's going down so there's a bunch
of very tangible things that are gonna
happen and you know it's I love having
this experience in knowing the
difference between animations are
advantages and disadvantages to each one
I don't frankly this might prefer one or
the other I like both experiences and
they're both unique but I do love and
I'm talking to Kathy quite a bit about
this as she's asking the differences
that I've experienced there's something
about the concrete nature of live action
it's incredibly spontaneous it's going
to happen right there the moment and
then that's it where I can tweak the
tiny eyebrow or a tiny smirk or give us
so cos it's a little bit of a push in a
direction that will dramatically change
the character you have to get all these
variables to kind of come together and
be aware of it and it's not like you're
controlling any of it as much as you're
guiding it and you know John looked at
me and speak this you know you're
looking at everything all at once we're
in the animation it's like a recipe that
I can keep adding little grease if you
have a lot of flexibility thank God in
digital and you post we can do a lot but
capturing that moment right in front of
you I think the real magic of it all
it's something that I've been craving to
try and luckily we have an incredible
crew and Casta can capture the smallness
and hopefully you saw in the footage but
yeah that's what I learned the most what
about the directors have season two
one is a new person - that hasn't been
announced yet who was working last night
that's our whole life teasing the
footage that the Mandalorian
everything's up this mask so when are we
are we going to see it do we ever
[Laughter]
you don't have to be in a costume
because yes so but I guess I do for as
you be in the costume versus a stunt
that's what well you know stunt doubles
are essential to every large production
just so if you know like even for the
strongest people or so nothing can get
done without the incredible stunt work I
mean especially wouldn't you guys see
that in 27 minutes or so can you only go
home
you have no idea the amount of star
power from every department that goes
into making something like this from you
know the person that is like you know
working on the shine of my shoulder to
the person who built the entire ship
that we're shooting on or the whole set
it's it's I've I've seen some I've seen
some I've seen some pretty big [ __ ] and
I haven't seen anything like this and so
yeah this does thank God
[Laughter]
in all my years yes you so I know the
footage we saw there were a lot of
references to this Star Wars Holiday
Special
that's where we saw it first Mandalorian
yes so you talked about why you wanted
to draw the draw that connect those
little to us there was a lot of I guess
there is will definitely lose the gun
right that yeah the pulse rifle just
here's the thing I wanted to have it
we're starting with new Karen's right
everybody there's all sorts of
conjecture is this really when he is it
did is it is it gonna really reveal that
it's moment fed all along is it a
character we already know we wanted to
start fresh with a whole new a whole new
set of characters that you never met
before and what's nice about that it's
like it
we were starting with Ironman so for new
fans did you know these were new
characters new actors and a new world
that NFA actually even the MCU in that
version of it was new so it was a really
nice entry point for people who wanted
who didn't know anything about Marvel
before I just wanted to see a movie and
they liked the actors that were in it
and we assume that you didn't know
anything and so we taught you introduce
you to everybody and but by the same
token the foundation of all of John rrah
is are the fans that have been there
since the beginning and the people who
grew up with it and so how do you
balance those two things at the same
time and I think for much of the time of
superhero films there was a there was
the notion going back you know decades
that the fans will be there anyway just
make it as approachable and accessible
as you can to the general audience but I
think that's changed a lot I think that
Kevin Feige and avi arad and all the
people who started off with with MCU I
think smartly realized was no those are
your fans that's who's been there along
and you build out from the grassroots so
never lose the touch with the people who
put in the time and who've cared and so
there are ways that even though we have
new characters in it you could jump in
because it's chapter one we wanted to
make sure that if you're watching and
you knew about it and this is where dave
has really been a treasure trove because
we we try to effort to work stuff in
whether it's humorously like making
reference to life day or a reference to
a prop that has been has been
appreciated by a core group over time
just putting
Easter eggs in or big movements in the
story that reflects storylines in either
the legends or in Captain that people
have known and had and by the way all of
the animated content that had that dates
been working on how do you leave all of
it together so that you don't have these
divided segmented parts of the you know
of the audience but you can start to
bring it all together and coalesce it in
a way that creates an overarching
narrative and rewards the people who
have been putting the time in over the
years since they were kids growing up
with it so that's where audiences sort
of a long-winded answer of why it's not
a life day joke in there but but that
those were things that ran some of it
was what I would write and want to see
if they've caught it and see what his
reaction would be in the present and he
had veto power over everything and he's
talking about like he's learning for me
but I'm learning just as much from him
and just tuning in on what is what is
too far where can we push it what are
the things that haven't been addressed
you want to yeah I mean John liked these
scripts turn around we wouldn't talk
sometimes does that be a Sam says it
would be on the phone and would you
start rallying and come up with a whole
block for an episode get you thought on
the phone okay Sam I haven't gotta go I
gotta go
boom okay and then like a day later
he'll read this on the go Wow
there's the script now I mean it's
really fun it is fun reading you know
John take on stars I would read
something like I see the holiday
specials back
[Applause]
you really like the holidays special we
know you have the gun in this show
because you like that you wanted to
happen
the courtship now it's in your office
and I get that like I never experienced
that before like you say I want to
design this I'm gonna have this and then
someone literally makes it walks up to
you enhance it you guys have an
innovation that's a may that either
makes you write it what we do it and I
see air to come Chang and all the
artists yeah the wall of artwork and by
the way that our work will be worked
into we're trying to let everybody see
their artwork let's put a damn a girl
but the artwork is the thing that makes
the show you know the art you know I'll
write something and then give it to them
and then by the time it goes through the
play-doh Fun Factory
Chiang of Gemini 11 I see these
beautiful images it's like you and then
you just write more yeah and sometimes I
don't even give just some pages to them
have them draw and then I said whether
they drawn I start writing and I start
writing things that are are impacted by
that's what I mean by a collaborative
environment that this allows well they
love that I react here's the five rivers
like how George would react to what I
would write the beginning and he'd be
like okay there we go
and then I have to give you that teach
you the ways of the force of The
Apprentice so maybe that's what's that's
what's been really great about it and
there is a discipline about it of like
let's make sure that we are authentic
disciplined cohesive and that no matter
where you're coming from and what your
background in Star Wars you know that
what we're doing is not being done it's
being done out of we've really
deliberated over it and discussed it and
thought it through
and so if we depart in any way it's we
know we are and if we but it's with a
plan and then part of it also is what's
the big art you know that's the other
thing that's the fun thing is the plan
and like there's some things around my
god I wonder if we're gonna think of
this but then we think about what you're
gonna think about it that we you might
not this move but you don't know that
move and that's just the fun part
especially in series yes we can make
that work even better they created aa
rock yeah yeah but just the feedback
honestly that you've all seen footage is
really not very exciting because that's
really the other hand it's it's a it's
it's media so it is a communication tool
between us and you and back again and
that's part of what we're getting
excited for well I think I can speak
well for everybody when I say we'd like
the holiday special
[Applause]